freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ihr lest richtig im titel ich
koche heute für den mann der als ich
klein war meine träume gelebt hat meine
fast food träume der mann der nach
amerika findet um den besten burger der
welt zu essen
jumbo schreiner jetzt richtig gehört
leute ich hab keine ahnung 24 stunden
erfahren dass ich meine möglichkeiten
hätte mit ihm zu drehen und ich habe mir
hier näherte biege bietet in düsseldorf
alles zusammengepackt eingekauft sehr
stressige stunden bis hierher auf jeden
fall aber jetzt fokussiere ich nicht
ganz darauf das beste essen zu machen
dass es gibt erst habe ich hier ich
mache aber das beste was die meisten
frühstück gemacht habe die bergführer
wir legen los und das sind die zutaten
die wir brauchen zwei gemüsezwiebeln
acht eier heckenschnitt lauter creme
fraiche und bürger warnt wir fangen an
indem wir die zwiebeln schneidet muss
mich jetzt erstmal zurechtfinden
das ist schon mal ein mäßiges brett ich
habe auf jeden fall noch mal mit einer
schönen küche gesucht und ich finde die
küche ist so richtig so
zu dessen liebe denn ich war mir dafür
gemüsezwiebel nehmen die sind halt
einfach größer süßer großes von vorteil
weil die ultra volumen verlieren wenn
sie hat kommentiert werden die süße ist
gut weil ich wie gesagt die
karamellisieren also die schneiden wir
so hin
feine scheiben und dann müssen wir auch
gleich schon einen topf mit wasser
parallel aufsetzen ich bin super excited
ich war wirklich komplett unter stress
die letzte zeit aber mittlerweile läuft
und dann machen wir den herrn jetzt
setzen wir in weiteren topf auf den herd
in den job fügen wir einen guten stich
butter hin zu den wir jetzt schmelzen
und dazu geben wir jetzt unsere zwiebel
so wie wenn man ein bisschen darum
versuche das ganze bisschen auseinander
zu bringen und dann müssen wir gleich
noch hier irgendwo zucker gluten nicht
den zucker darüber zwei drei teelöffel
würde ich das ganze ein und werden allen
weiteren vorbereitung bleibt das ja auch
nur sitzen fällt zusammen karamellisiert
und sehr sehr leckere an
und dann noch ein bisschen salz dazu wir
gehen jetzt auf unsere top mit wasser
eine glasschüssel drauf das wasser steht
nur so hoch dass es nicht die schüssel
berührt so können wir nämlich das ei
dass wir darin ist zubereiten werden
indirekten schonend zubereiten und ich
schmeiße unseren ofen auf 200 grad ist
grün
wir gehen jetzt acht eier in unsere
glasschüssel so ich würde das ganze
jetzt konstant also ganz wichtig dass
man nicht absetzt so wird es einem super
super wie ihr seht hier die eier werden
jetzt langsam so ein bisschen wie sagt
man die kriegen so kleine knoten drin
aber es ist trotzdem noch sehr flüssig
das ganze dann gehen wir einen weiteren
esslöffel butter hinein und einen
großzügigen esslöffel creme fraiche ich
gebe mir immer mühe alle amerikanischen
oder zettel die ich benutze aus amerika
zu beziehen und alle italienischen aus
italien sowie können wir jetzt ein
bisschen schnittlauch rein früheren den
auch noch unter ja ja eine sehr schöne
konsistenz es ist auch zeit für uns die
vom herd zu nehmen also so sollten
unsere außen wenn sie fertig sind so
schön so ein widerstand flowfact gebe
ich mal noch ein wenig butter in die
pfanne schmelzen wie rachel dann
thorsten wir unsere brötchen haben gehen
wir unsere brötchen rein
es gibt nichts auf dieser welt was nicht
eine schöne schein
besser so ich will jetzt entdecken hier
raus leute so sieht sehr schön aus dem
becken so ein bisschen mario rhein dann
worcester source das wollen wir ein so
leute hier sind alle zutaten
karamellisierte zwiebeln unsere spicy
mario berger wans angetastet bacon käse
so ich fange jetzt an zusammen zu bauen
wäre auch schon von hungrigen augen
angeschaut werde vielleicht schon wo
erst mal im video sehen gegeben oben und
unten ein bisschen von der sp mario
drauf also erstmal unsere eine lage ein
dann kommt darauf die karamellisierten
zwiebeln dann kommt auf die oberseite
unser denken und jetzt geben wir den
käse drauf und der käse wird
angeschmolzen in der käse an geschmolzen
ist ich habe mir zu
so so katja ersten herzlich willkommen
in meinem video hier ist der brave
bürger durch beide zubereitet habt das
ganze läuft bei mir auf dem kanal so ab
wir sind erstmal ein bisschen kleiner
kommt drauf an für dich ist der klein
für mich ist ganz gewiss aber nicht der
große frühstück presserat ohne espresso
geht gar nix der kommt espresso brauche
ich immer das ist quasi wie wenn beim
auto die batterie kaputt ist ja du
kommst mit dem kabel
damals besaß das ist mein espresso
ok-sprecher in kalter saft fenster auf
wenn wir bei mir zu hause während
kätzchen reden wir nicht lange rum dass
leute jeder bürger hat das marketing ist
alles okay sie nimmt den ersten bisschen
radikaler aus die last komplett
aufdrücken wert gehen aufs essen erst
dann wird die kamera wieder an die
bewährte ist das frühstück was sagt
manfred böckl server und morgen allen
strecken sprechen allerdings seiner
objekte bald ist klar wir sehen dass
gleich alle teller sind leer gefegt wird
ein café guten morgen guten uhr bin ich
sehr gespannt was du sagst nummer eins
im kasten
das ist aber das ist ein verdienst an
katja muss man dazu deswegen liebe ich
sie auch später im krieg kein kaffee
mehr
nummer zwei und das recht nicht mehr
sehr hoch an muss ganz kurz ausholen
wenn du so galileo geschichten machst ja
wir kochen
wir informieren über das was wir kommen
dann kommt das gekochte schön
angerichtet auf dem teller dann findest
du das und kommen bei den redakteuren
dass man manchmal momente das und dann
kommen wir doch bis das heißt bei mir
landet ist das ding kälter als vorher
bevor du angefangen hast zu kommen es
war plötzlich heißt dein blog
ich mag die art von herzhaften frühstück
okay gibt daher ist oder hast du der
schinken alles ich bin eher der salzige
tja ich finde das gut
die kombination ist super ich habe mir
ein haushalts noch dann gewünscht okay
aber ich bin seit gestern was mir
wirklich gut geschmeckt hat um top war
die soße ist ja so wenn man mit der
sauce übertreibt in der früh
das muss leicht bekannt sein und den tag
einleiten und das war absolut der fall
also ich muß schon mal sagen ich glaube
das ist die differenzierte antwort die
ich auch die frage wie hat es geschmeckt
bisher bekommen aber in diesem format
wenn das ganze jetzt bewerten ist es auf
einer skala von 0 bis 10
was würdest du der sache gehen zeichnet
zahlen mit den fingern mit einer hand
und ich zeig dir eine zahl 123 befindet
und das sind zwei sind die 9,7 für den
frühstücks bürger marien auf deinem
leute wirklich gut aber hat natürlich
auch was damit zu tun dass er ab heute
das ding jederzeit zu jeder uhrzeit für
mich machen zum mittagessen sollte wird
es spanisch ganz passend zu katar als
neuem song der jetzt ausgekommen des
spanische tapas spanische liebe
[Musik]
und wenn ich leiste wird gibt's
spanische spanier haben wir also alles
daher wissen wir hätten jetzt gehört das
zum mittagessen das ist immer eine
herausforderung weil man relativ viel
auf einmal machen muss ich habe mir was
vorbereitet und ich muss eigentlich
sogar noch parallel das abendessen das
vorbereiten dementsprechend viel zu tun
wir machen erstmal die einfachste sache
zuerst oliven ich habe sehr gute lieben
gekauft und den fertig brauchen wir alt
das hier weil es ist zehn jahre her ich
tomaten peter ich weiß dass die
vermieter von ferienautos videoschauen
werden tut mir leid ich habe keinen
honig gehabt und habe mich einfach mal
bedient ich nehme mal ganz klein
bisschen also wir bereiten hier einfach
mal vor das hier ist noch offen form
nehmen unseren peter und dem rechtlich
ein bisschen zurecht sodass wir hier gut
reinpasst geformt und dann völlig
einfach so ein bisschen die ränder auf
tragische weise kommt ja nicht und daher
dann nehmen wir einfach weil es die
frauen die beides ist ein bisschen
kleiner patienten gehen nicht mit in den
ofen mit sind noch ein video in ein paar
worte da lassen ja dave gehört wir
führen ein wenig thymian zu unseren
ziegenkäse hinzu kann man aber auch
einfach ganz lassen die erste gibt er
nur ein bisschen geschmack ab und dann
nebenher etwas von diesem unglaublich
geil motiven
hier seht ihr schon meine vorbereitung
aber schneidet für den fehler erst mal
noch die cherrytomaten viertel nach oben
drüber
und das kommt dann einfach so in den
ofen ich kann doch nicht geschnitten
habgierig die großen habe ich ein
zweites mal
jetzt kommt man schon ein fachmann
überschüsse die kommen gleich ins
kochende bastert ich weiß nicht ob das
gerade auf der kamera war es schon wo
das gesagt hat aber der satz alles ist
mit bacon besser ist gefallen das ist
scheinbar so tun muss lebens motto ich
hab davon mit back also darin im
speckmantel 30 ich habe dafür gibt es
quasi eigentlich auch kein rezept
sondern man nimmt halt den speck eine
dattel holz schön eng einschneidet up
fertig und das mache ich jetzt ein paar
datteln wenn man das meinen zehnjährigen
ich erzählt hätte dass ich mal führt
jumbo koche ich hätte es nicht geglaubt
ist man hätte es wahrscheinlich auch mir
vor einem jahr erzählen können als ich
so ein bisschen luft unterwegs und ich
genau wusste ein paar stückchen weiter
dass man überhaupt hätte ich
wahrscheinlich auch an sich geglaubt so
ich bin jetzt mal das wasser hier zum
kochen für ordentlich salz hinzu
wir geben einen teelöffel backpulver
dazu das mache ich eigentlich immer wenn
ich etwas mit kartoffeln mache es macht
ihr einfach unfassbar knusprig weil
dadurch die oberfläche vergrößert wird
dann gehen wir auch schon unsere
kartoffeln hinein und kommen sie für
zehn minuten vorn hier fressen jetzt 3
knoblauchzehen hinein wollen aber nicht
dass der knoblauch brown wird also
darauf jeden fall drauf aufpassen
knoblauch geben wir noch ein wenig zeit
und ich würde auch dazu geben wir nicht
wissen wo welcher ist dann nehmen wir
uns unser kochendes wasser
ich finde ich hier ruhig ein bisschen
abdanken und jetzt rennen wir den
knoblauch vom öl aber mit einem kleinen
sie den wagen auf und fügen ihn zum
schluss wieder entwerfen wir sie ein
bisschen hin und her um an der
oberfläche ein kartoffelbrei artige
textur zu erzeugen so sollte das ganze
aussehen dann machen wir unseren
backofen auf und gehen jetzt für 20
minuten in den ofen wir machen zwei
damit unseren alben die gas dazu gebe
ich zunächst so ein paar takte war in
das englische befreien
so kommt auch dazu dann ein dazu kommen
zwei großzügige esslöffel paniermehl 250
gramm hackfleisch ist auch verpasst
und dann verrät ich das ganze jetzt
fahren wir unsere von tigers eine pfanne
mit öl heiß werden
jetzt warten wir die einfach schön von
allen seiten golden an oben braten die
algen die gassen sind die kartoffeln
fast fertig ich stehe jetzt den
ziegenkäse mit dazu machen wir mal zu
übernehmen wir uns don quixote aufbaus
und geben in die pfanne eine halbe
zwiebel und eine halbe knoblauch sehr
runter mit der hitze das alles so ein
bisschen andünsten
dabei geben wir einen teelöffel zucker
karamellisieren wie die zwiebeln
bisschen thymian dazu eine dose
geschälte tomaten dazu dass wir weit
kommen und verteilen sie so ein bisschen
und ich sag's dazu und chilipulver wir
die paar kopfhörer auf und wir geben
unsere daten im speckmantel rein sondern
jetzt ist alles
[Musik]
jung war es jetzt lange genug unterwegs
eine kleine stärkung der mir als tigers
ziegenkäse mit honig weil essen und
cherrytomaten tatsache das einzige mal
dass ich gesehen habe dass ihre augen zu
glänzen ist als ich mit einem
blumenstrauß nach hause gekommen bin und
da habe ich was angestellte schau dir
jetzt die augen die sie gelesen
das sind sozusagen niveau auch gerne auf
dem tollwood rechne weil spanien dann
bitte nicht über dir sagen rheinischen
ich würde sagen reinschieben ja und da
waren dieses ensemble für mich meine
favorite also ich hab mit apotheke und
das erzählt neues zu der theorie
es ist keine von continental nichts
sagen sondern die kamera geht jetzt aus
mit sich bei der ist ja quasi schon zu
halten haben wir schweigen teller sind
leer gefegt bin sehr gespannt ob er hats
drauf aber das ist nicht das schlimmste
davon was gekriegt haben gesagt ja was
ich bei dir ein bisschen schon
der käse der käse mit einer nasenspitze
vorn aber die hackbällchen sehr gut weil
frischer knoblauch und richtig locker
wir sind zum glück wenn man schon das
noble steht dann soll es wenigstens gut
geschmeckt haben
blöd wenn du irgendwie oktober schlinks
und das war die 1 euro für ein kilo
billige kuppel auf dem döner die
hackbällchen leider hinter den zehn
thesen aber der ziegenkäse oder richtig
bombe kein mitglied schon weiter es ist
alles alles wirklich gut ich hätte mir
gibt das weiß man bei der millionenfrage
habt ja beantwortete er sagt er habe ich
liebe 1
ansonsten hättest du auf jedes einzelne
die volle punktzahl so kommen vor
aber weil juli person allergie paste ist
alle bioly ist es nicht ich sage 959 für
das geschirr okay das ergebnis weiter in
die vermieter hier aber ich finde auch
das ist sehr sehr gut gepasst hat
die 9,5 absolute hammer an dir ist ein
spanier verloren
dann gucken wir jetzt mal ob ich auch
pizza kann dann mache ich jetzt weiter
so leute willkommen zum abend erst jetzt
richtig gehört pizza ich habe tage
vorbereitet schon vor 24 stunden
angefangen das ist ja immer noch recht
zeitintensiv in sachen aber hier ist auf
jeden fall schon sehr viel liebe drin
denen ist gleich ausrollen der pizza
ofen heizt schon vor und dann belege ich
das ganze mit einer tomatensoße cia habe
ich schon ein bisschen angebraten und
damit ihr auch auf jeden fall durch
erste pole für mozzarella dich ein
bisschen abtropfen lassen habe damit der
feuchtigkeit anteil nicht so hoch ist ja
und ansonsten gibt es eigentlich gar
nicht viel zu sagen ist eine simple
geschichte ich pizza wird gerade dann
gut wenn man es simpel hält was ist die
beste pizza die große kraft pizza immer
die nächste ist jetzt sehr gut weil ihr
seid so nah an das sogar deswegen sind
sich auch hier noch extrem gechillt und
nunmehr ein bisschen die arbeitsfläche
das ist immer die große schwierigkeit
die erste pizza direkt gut hinzubekommen
die späteren werden in der regel gut was
sollte aus cloppenburg auch noch ein
bisschen drüber kraft ingo weiss man
salat
judenburg form den rand kraft ist meine
fraktion andré marion kracht gute
anregung ihres glaube die zweite dritte
wird wie immer ein bisschen besser dann
lebe ich die viele hilfe mozzarella form
ist auf jeden fall noch nicht ganz
perfekt aber besser ist wenn sie nun
perfekt ist so und dann unsere sales die
pizza backt ja nur 90 sekunden oder
vielleicht ein bisschen länger
dementsprechend ist es auf jeden fall
die sichere variante die sit ja vorher
schon anzubraten also wir feuern seien
direkt ein bisschen runter jetzt der
hitze seht schon hinten kommt der rand
direkt hoch leute meine kamera ist aus
einem grund voll obwohl ich gerade 60 gb
daten wieder statt häufig auf die gruppe
wächst nicht packe ich glaube er weiß
was ihr blüht
naja du weisst was das ist ja der partei
und du weißt was passiert wenn den paten
die peter nicht
der kräftige hat eine pizza für mich die
mich eine pizza von liebe und
leidenschaft
aus der alten heimat aus dt music
ausprobiert ihr kennt den spaß die
kammer geht auch und dann packe ich noch
zwei drei weitere pizzen aber erstmal
kennen sie die nichts an und sieht
jedoch verfahren
wir haben es gleich gedanken ersetzen
wir also sorry nochmal was passiert und
auch diese kamera ist aber ich würde
gerne über schlechtes sein aber ich
lasse es werden mit katja just schaut
aus doch auch wenn du hast und ich weiß
nicht ob du hilfe hat es bei der auswahl
was ist extrem genau das auf den punkt
getroffen was ich auch bestellen sie das
gelände dadurch schwierig was das nicht
ich sage es mal so ich habe bestimmt in
den letzten zehn jahren unzählige
skizzen gegessen die weit unter seiner
leiterin und da waren alle lernen dass
auch die vertreten
super garpunkt extrem gut so schaut eine
pizza aus dem süden ab und kommt flüssig
und ich sag das jetzt mal so jetzt den
ersten bisschen gemacht die leute hier
und hat so gemacht hat und dem tisch
das beste an der ganzen kiste ist die
kommen dazu aus der nicht über würsten
tomatensoße ist nicht über wird es ganz
wenigen und der leichte schärfe die aus
dieser als sicher bekannte kommt und er
gibt nichts zu meckern das schlechteste
an dieser pizza ist die kamera
das ist die pid für mich beziehen die
pizza ist für mich nur zehn und ich
würde mit dieser pizza stolz gestellt in
jedem italienischen laden rein gehen mit
dem handy nutzer guckst du diese man
macht der pc richtig so weiter
das ist nicht sehr ich hatte somit kommt
es häufig nicht den super super super
brot für diese ganzen bewährt mit zehn
zu beenden ist wirklich der hammer
ihr habt ja beim herd hand gesagt habe
ich sagte zu ihm angespannt sie den kopf
und ich sag's dir mir das nur im ansatz
schlecht ist werde ich sie noch sagen
weil ich habe auch einen ruf zu dir hast
du kannst du hingehen und kannst jeden
der die lobhudelei machen ja zwei extra
herzen weil dort ein ganz toller
gastgeber unbedingt dann vielleicht
nicht hier sondern bei mir zu hause aber
wir sehen uns am nächsten sondern
spätestens wieder für die nächste folge
einfach persönlicher kopf macht
[Musik]